hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number
129 hard to believe it is that many live
streams but uh you know the numbers
don't lie i mean they can be made to lie
but we wouldn't have done that and here
we are
so uh here we are yeah brett weinstein
heather hein coming to you as we so
often do on saturdays yes dr brett
weinstein dr heather hein it is
non-doctor fair june
3rd or 4th 4th it is the 4th of june of
course everybody knows that
and um
yeah i came up with a really really
funny joke to um
set the live stream in motion excellent
unfortunately i came up with it in the
shower and state dependent learning
being what it is
i don't remember what it was it was
funny you'll have to trust me on that
though it was it was good and just
getting back into the shower to remember
it would not have been worth the time so
no i don't think so yeah i won't dwell
on it though no i wouldn't let it go
already have you
mostly it's not totally evident
today we are going to talk about um
about a number of broad issues about
where we find ourselves in in society is
it good where we find ourselves
there are rays of hope
there's a hopeful note or two in here
you're right about there there are
hopeful notes and the fact is that what
what we are trying to do is speak truth
where we find it as we see it
come what may and of course this is part
of why we have found ourselves on the on
the wrong end of certain sticks wielded
by certain authorities
as they as they would prefer that we not
speak certain
truths or investigate certain ideas but
the fact that our audience continues to
grow despite what some platforms may
suggest about the numbers
suggests that there are an awful lot of
people out there who are in fact
not buying into the idea that all you
have to do to know what's going on
is let the authorities tell you so we're
going to investigate a number of ideas
today including um a return to some
concepts that you have you have talked
about before including the sort of
growing
epidemic of sophistry as it were
how about we go there um in light of uh
in light of this movie that came out
this week neither of us have seen but
it's
a lot of people talking about it and
we've watched the clips
um the what is a woman movie that matt
walsh i think directed starred in uh
that's uh
that's on the daily wire platform
and it it asks
it asks a question of our time what is a
woman which has a really simple answer
and which many many many people seem to
be uh
refusing to engage with that simplicity
because it doesn't serve them in their
sophistry in their sophistry yeah which
they do not recognize as such presumably
but right
uh so but before that we will we will
spend some time talking um about whether
or not for instance we find ourselves in
a dark age
as has been proposed uh by
by one excellent clear-headed thinker so
first however some logistics we have um
this
in the last week we have had both the
french and the spanish editions of
hunter-gatherers guide to the 21st
century come out here is in fact we
haven't received the spanish one yet but
here's the here's the i can't get that
flat with the camera uh here's the
french version
um
i'm not gonna do it i was i was going to
see how to pronounce it weren't you yeah
but then i actually forgot to look up
how you say 21st i don't remember how
you say first
um i was going to say 21
century in french and that's that's just
bad so that's my excuse for not trying
to say
i'm like i did
a doctor gatherer which we had
a dear friend of ours and former student
of ours who is i don't think she's um a
native french speaker but her mother is
and so she's completely bilingual i
don't i don't think it's her
her first language exactly but she's
completely fluent in french and uh she
said it for us she we got to spend some
time with her this week and she said it
for us over and over and over again and
still i thought
my tongue just doesn't want to do that
yeah right now when i think about it we
should have had her
record it and record it that wouldn't
record it we missed that
yeah how do we miss that anyway um we're
actually going to be recording not in
we will be speaking in english but
recording a lot of hours of spanish
language interviews that will be
translated this week so for
we hear from a lot of people uh in
spanish-speaking countries and for whom
spanish is their first language who have
been waiting for the spanish edition of
the book and here it comes it's it's
available now
okay if you're watching um actually i've
been told that odyssey is not working
again this week so if you're watching on
youtube keep watching on youtube
if you're if this is later and you're
watching on spotify or you're listening
great that works too
we with regard to products we haven't
put out any new products in a while
we've got a cool new shirt coming it's
not available just yet but uh next week
or the week after i think they're gonna
like it i think i think they are too so
you can look at some of our existing
merchandise at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and look forward to something new soon
at natural selections this week my sub
stack i won't i woke
[Music]
i wrote about some of the downstream
effects of some things including woke
ideology and also
homelessness policy in many west coast
and other but especially west coast
cities so go there that seems to have
been well received
finally uh with regard to logistics
before we embark on the main part of the
podcast we are as
you all know supported by our audience
we appreciate you subscribing to the
channel to both this channel and to the
clips channel liking and sharing
uh there on on odyssey or youtube or
spotify and we have for instance a new
clip out today that came out of our
private monthly q a this month which you
can access on our on my patreon uh we
encourage you to join either of our
patreons brett had a great conversation
this morning on on his
and uh and also
the main podcast
for for a while now and maybe for you
know maybe forever we'll have an
addition to our live streams another
episode with brett uh and a guest this
week's that just that came out this week
was with neil oliver i haven't listened
to all of it but the parts that i have
listened to so far are just fabulous and
you know the two of you were
amazing and uh in combination in
conversation it's terrific yeah it was
quite a good conversation i really
enjoyed it the feedback on it has been
stellar people have um really enjoyed
hearing the two of us chat and i will
say that there was at least one
uh sort of important
new idea for me at least dropped in
there which neil and i have
been kind of
pursuing a little bit farther back
channel since the thing emerged so
anyway there will be another
conversation at some point and we will
further pursue the question of whether
or not
the
force that
seeks to corral us
is
has become shy of what neil calls the
wet work involved in the tyrannies of
the 20th century or whether it may have
moved into a new phase anyway i think
it's a really important question so uh
if that all seems
cryptic to you check out this episode
well remotely applied tyranny is
certainly easier probably cheaper and a
less gory than uh and close up yeah and
it's easier to rationalize
yeah yeah yeah
um
okay so you can um you know what
excuse me
just a reminder that last summer youtube
demonetized us and we're still
demonetized our channels are live but
we make no money through youtube
and uh that was a potential source of
our income
so we appreciate all of the support uh
liking the channel support you know
subscribing to the channel sharing the
pieces if you can afford it we obviously
appreciate financial support you can ask
one of the ways that you can do that is
through our q a
at the
after most of our episodes including
today we'll have a live q a
darkwaresubmissions.com
you can join the patreons and of course
we have sponsors we are very grateful to
our sponsors
uh all of whom have products or services
that we actually vouch for or we have uh
friends whom we have shared the products
with and they vouch for and uh that is
true for all three of our sponsors this
week so without further ado
let us do that
our first sponsor this week is vivo
barefoot
shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be and be
constrained by vivos are made by people
who know feet these shoes are a
revelation we love them
they'll be uncomfortable i was just
walking around in the rain and the cool
and the rain in early june the pacific
northwest in them today and they are
they're amazing
uh they cause no pain at all because
there are no pressure points forcing
your feet into odd positions our feet of
course are the products of millions of
years of evolution we evolved to walk
move and run barefoot but modern shoes
are often overly cushioned and strangely
shaped and that has negatively impacted
foot function and are contributing to a
health crisis one of many things of
course contributing to a health crisis
but most people's shoes
contribute to their lack of willingness
to move very much because their shoes
make their feet hurt not so vivo
barefoot they are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around at them
number of people wearing vivo barefoots
is growing once people start wearing
these shoes they don't seem to stop
they've got a great range of footwear
for kids and adults and for every
activity from hiking to training to
everyday wear they're certified b corp
pioneering regenerative business
principles and their footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild in it
go to vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get
an exclusive offer of twenty percent off
additionally all new customers get a
hundred day free trial so you can see if
you love them as much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash dark horse
our second sponsor this week is ned a
cbd company that stands out in a highly
saturated cbd market
ned was started by two friends who
discovered that their hyper modern lives
were leaving them feeling and i quote
from their site empty bewildered and
disconnected something about this way of
life just wasn't working so they started
then you can buy cbd products in nearly
every coffee shop at grocery store but
ned's blends stand out their de-stress
blend in particular really impresses us
that's distress blend is a one-to-one
formula of cbd and cbg
made from the world's purest
full-spectrum hemp and also features a
botanical infusion of ashwagandha
cardamom and cinnamon cbg is known as
quote the mother of all cannabinoids
because of how effective it is at
combating anxiety and stress by
inhabiting
inhibiting the reuptake of gaba the
neurotransmitter responsible for stress
regulation
many of the cbd companies out there
source their hemp from industrial farms
in china just like with low quality
alcohol though low quality cbd can have
undesired effects because of course it
can
that is usda certified organic it's
extracted from usda certified organic
hemp plants the full spectrum hemp oil
is grown by an independent farmer named
jonathan in peonia colorado and ned
shares third-party lab reports and
information about who farms the products
and their extraction process on their
site it's very transparent
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs
they're full of premium cbd and a full
spectrum of active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes ned's full
spectrum hemp oil nourishes the body's
endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance
so fortify your stress response this
month and get 15 off ned's de-stress
blend with code darkhorse go to
helloned.com darkhorse or enter code
darkhorse at checkout that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d dot com slash darkhorse
to get 15 off and we thank ned for
sponsoring the show and offering our
listeners a natural remedy for some of
life's most common health issues
all right
our final sponsor this week is md
hearing aid say what
md hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone could afford recognizing that
about 95 percent of the people who need
a hearing aid only require a few
settings he removed some of the less
often needed components he also cut out
the middleman
and now md hearing aid makes a
rechargeable hearing aid that is fda
registered and costs a small fraction of
what typical hearing aids cost
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will ever know you're
wearing them the rechargeable batteries
last up to 30 hours their volt plus is
water resistant up to three feet in up
to three feet of water and you don't
need a prescription to get one you buy
it directly from the source where
audiologists and licensed hearing aid
specialists are available seven days a
week everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and here's what
she said
she said with my particular type of
hearing loss a deep male voice in a
noisy room is the hardest situation for
me to hear and understand
i wore md hearing aid
to have a conversation with a deep
voiced man in a room with a lot of white
noise the md hearing aid passed the test
as my conversation partner's voice was
clear and understandable at a price
point of under a thousand dollars i was
amazed at how effective these are
md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45-day
risk-free trial with 100 money-back
guarantee get clinic level care
for 80 less with md hearing aids go to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
darkhorse to get their buy one get one
deal a pair of hearing aids cost just
300 bucks 299.99 plus darkhorse
listeners receive a free extra charging
case
a hundred dollar value so head to mdmd
mdmdhearingaid.com
and use the promo code darkhorse or you
can call them at 1-833-772-1392
all right okay
we are going to start
uh by sharing
some bits from an essay that our friend
alexander mourinho shared with us and a
few other friends this morning
which both of us were uh
were both
amazed by for how much it resonates with
things we have thought and also
i speak only for myself because we
haven't actually talked about much more
than that um
the way that the author puts some things
together um that we have thought and put
some things together in some new ways
so if you will share my screen here for
a bit zach
this is a
oh
yeah you don't have the power to
share my screen yet in part because
there's a cat's tail between the cable
and the wow i
will just see if i pinned the cat in
place here can you share my screen now
zack
okay well
i will
i will begin okay
so this is
um by a man named steve patterson it's
on his site
and published in about a year ago a
little less than a year ago june 25th
2021
in which he posits uh that we are in
fact and have been not that we are now
entering but that we have been in a dark
age and uh although he doesn't explore
it in this essay in in part one which is
so far the only uh the only part yet
published
but that we actually may be seeing signs
that we could be emerging from that dark
age which is
rather hopeful i'm not sure i'm not i'd
like to see the evidence for that laid
out as clearly as he's laid out the
evidence for the idea that we are
actually in a dark age now uh but let me
just you can keep on my screen although
that didn't work um
yeah take take off my screen for a
moment i think when we plugged in
everything got
strangerfied on my screen so now you can
share my screen again
uh here's just a pdf
of the same essay the very same
assignment will of course link to this
in the show notes as as we always do i
just want to share a few bits and have
us talk about uh the events that i'm
sharing from this
darkness everywhere patterson writes
by and again the the thesis is we are in
a dark age and we have been in fact for
most of the since since early in the
20th century
he says by a dark age i do not mean that
all modern beliefs are false
the earth is indeed round indeed i mean
that all of our structures of knowledge
are plagued by errors at all levels from
the trivial to the profound periphery to
the fundamental
nothing that you've been taught can be
believed because you were taught it
nothing can be believed because others
believe it no idea is trustworthy
because it's written in a textbook
and this you know this this will
resonate with many of our viewers of
course
this is this is what it looks like this
is what it feels like in the modern era
to say you can't trust an authority on
the basis that they are in authority
and every authority absolutely must earn
your trust
before they weren't
being let into your brain frankly and of
course that's a dicey business because
how is it that you let someone into your
brain in order to figure out uh if you
do in fact trust them without having let
them in where they can perhaps muck
things up and uh and muddle about with
how you're thinking
so uh there are a number of things
obviously you and i were both struck by
this essay i think we do need to say and
i've now confirmed with him we i didn't
know who this person was until i read
this essay and then i reached out to him
uh
and
confirmed that in fact there is a
reference in there um he mentions the
scientist who discovers there's a
problem with lab rats
i believe he's referring to me i'm
pretty sure that's right but he is at
least aware of us and so some of this
may not be totally independent but
there is a
a fact here which is that we have
converged on an understanding and this
is a
strongly suggested piece of evidence
right the idea that multiple people
starting in different places arrive at
the same
conclusion which is that you know we
have a system in which our mechanism for
figuring out what is true is so broadly
untrustworthy
that in fact you cannot look at a
textbook and say this is generally right
right um now of course this puts you he
doesn't mention in in this essay but
this of course puts you in a familiar
predicament because
descartes was of course troubled by the
fact that almost everything descartes
ronan descartes rene descartes i heard
dick hart dickhart what is this i don't
know who we're talking about dick
gephardt was in a totally different
predicament but okay uh descartes was in
a predicament he was in a predicament
because he recognized that almost
everything he knew he did not know
directly and that that raised the
possibility that a lot of it just simply
wasn't right now of course you can
absolutely paralyze yourself with that
recognition the question is
what do you do how much do you accept
because people basically generally
believe it and how much are you
skeptical of things that people
generally believe because sometimes
those things are dead wrongs there's a
kind of an art form to
figuring out how to separate the wheat
from the chaff and especially in the
modern era when there is so much to know
when no human being could possibly know
all of the things that human beings that
some human beings know
you have to decide either to be
completely unaware of huge a huge
fraction of what other human beings talk
about
and we all do that to some degree
but
and
you have to figure out to some degree
who is it that you're going to outsource
your thinking to on x topic
and
one of and we'll get here i'm going to
just quickly walk through as as we talk
um
each of his six main points each of his
six main sort of lines of evidence for
why he thinks we're in a dark age now
um
and part part of what we're seeing
is that people have outsourced frankly
science
so many people decided
you know for a lot of reasons many of
which we've talked about on air
that oh i don't do science i'm not mathy
i don't do that sort of thing and part
of that is because sometimes people
really you know aren't that good at it's
not what they're drawn to but a lot of
it is about a really crappy early
educational system which
teaches science badly which teaches math
badly and so
confirms for people that they're not
good at things which they certainly
could have been good at and actually are
obliged to at least be
be literate in i've made the point on
dark horse before
that being illiterate
is not tolerated in coastal
intelligentsia circles whereas being
innumerate is actually almost a badge of
honor like you know you can talk about
being math phobic
or enumerate and have people say well of
course aren't we all and you certainly
wouldn't be able to say that about your
ability to read a newspaper article but
if you if you acknowledge that actually
you just kind of gloss over even the
really basic math presented in newspaper
articles that explains in part why even
the really basic math presented in
newspaper articles is so often bad and
wrong because no one no one seems to be
checking it yeah like literally no one
is checking it well enough for it to get
caught before
you know it emerges in public just the
most jaw-dropping you know errors orders
of magnitude off and transparently so
for example
um but
so the number there are a number of
things one to notice that we are in some
kind of a dark age is like step one
step two is to figure out what to do
about it right how you know are you
going to allow your thinking process to
just be completely ground to a halt by
the fact that you can't trust things or
are you going to figure out you know
which ice is thick enough for you to put
your weight on and which ice isn't and
you know so there are little tricks like
um
there are features
of
a
thought process if you're trying to make
headway on a difficult problem
sometimes there's
um
a something that you have to believe in
order to make progress downstream that
you know is suspect and the question is
how do you allow that
placeholder belief to exist
while not compromising everything that
you build on top of it and so you sort
of have to maintain
a an awareness of what rests on the
truth of this thing which i suspect
probably isn't quite true and to what
extent do you know if it is refined and
it turns out to be sort of 80 of the way
there what what falls apart of what
you've just done because some assumption
was off by a substantial amount yeah it
requires
a sort of a probabilistic kind of
thinking about it about decision trees
including intellectual decision trees
wherein
uh does you know does the bow does the
there's a limb that you climb out on in
order to explore some idea
if it were an actual tree it would need
to absolutely 100 barrier weight and if
it is completely rotten it will fall
immediately and hopefully that will be
revealed too in the metaphorical space
of of ideas
um but what about if it's not exactly
what you think it is and if you start
jumping up and down on it it would start
to crack but it's good enough for now
like what of the things that you are
going to try to explore
i guess downstream i want to say
upstream here but you know downstream of
that decision to go out on that limb
is
is contingent on you being on exactly
that limb and what isn't you know this
is this is complexity space this is this
is
hard and it's impossible to do perfectly
well and that's the thing it doesn't
have to be perfect right um but actually
it occurs to me now that we're talking
about it
that
when done correctly
meta-analysis is a formalization of this
process you can't do meta-analysis on
informal topics it has to be
you know it's basically a way of
compiling data that was collected in
different ways into a synthetic analysis
but the point is in a meta-analysis
if you
discover that
one of the studies in question was
either badly done right that there's
some terrible flaw in it or that it
wasn't done at all and it's a fraud then
the point is it isn't that well
that analysis was inside of your
meta-analysis your meta-analysis is
garbage the answer is okay what if we
turn that one to zero what happens to
the remainder of the analysis because
you know exactly how contingent the
conclusion was on any given piece of
evidence so
it is the question is how do you take
that line of logic
and apply it to things that are not uh
algorithmic right how do you how do you
figure out what's true in a world of
uncertain uh data that you can't check
for uncertain evidences i'm going to try
to stop talking about data because it's
really evidence that that matters
but
i will say so i think i said
some weeks ago that i had occasionally
go back to my own twitter feed
and search it for the term
dark age and that i found that i had
been tweeting about a dark age since
2009 when i signed up for twitter and i
know that i was talking about it before
then but at least i can go back that far
and say
you know not a new thought
the idea that the dark age might go back
to early in the 20th century
i had not yep i hadn't thought that
that's a new idea for for me as well
although it's consistent with
a lot of what we have been talking about
with regard to
the financial model of the modern
university and of science in particular
uh
playing into
people's worst instincts around who to
trust and where the incentives are yes
and
it
the incentives not only do they pollute
everything that comes out of that
structure so that it is suspect but they
also train the people who might
otherwise have become high quality
scientists to become the inverse right
by putting them through a sales training
program you take them out of the mind
frame of falsification
and
so at the at the conference in bath one
of the things that i said that
apparently resonated with people was
just for people who aren't paying as
close attention right yes so i went to
this conference in bath which was uh a
lot of
coveted dissidents was the central
sort of theme of the conference and i
was hosting a panel on the question of
um how do we recapture
science and my contention was you can't
because even if you fixed all of the
incentives so that would work there
aren't enough people in it who remember
how to do it such that if you know if
you fixed it and rebooted it it wouldn't
run you have to rebuild it right and
that is
um
you know it's just happenstance i guess
but it resonates very well with this
essay in the sense that
you know yes the system that is supposed
to figure out what's true has been
diverted into some other activity and
now it's not like nobody knows how to do
it but
the system is mostly a potemkin village
of science it's not the real thing yeah
so you know patterson uh i i think is
arguing although i'm not i don't think
he explicitly does it here um that
the failure of academia in concert in in
you know in synchronicity with the rise
of academia as producing what the world
is supposed to regard as the people who
are authorities on all the subjects
um is the is the combination that has
taken us down and so certainly in
science we see this so you know you need
you need what's called a terminal degree
you know you need a phd or an md
depending um in order to have sort of
standing in science or medicine by which
you then are
are allowed to say things in many
circles and this is this is a style of
thinking about scientific thinking and
medical thinking that we have been
we have been arguing against since
before we ourselves had phds
and of course it is it is easier for
people with the terminal degrees that
are required by the system to say
actually that's a terrible metric and
it's a terrible metric because
uh of you know all of the ways that the
system is actually canalizing people um
also cannibalizing people in a way but
canalizing people slotting people into
highly specialist regimes out of which
they cannot see and um
once there it becomes both difficult to
think and it becomes difficult to choose
to go outside because now their entire
livelihoods depend on being in this you
know in this path in this canal to use
the developmental term canalized so
let's just share a little bit more here
um you may share my screen if you like
zack
why did this happen patterson asks and
he has six ideas and we're gonna just
just
i'm going to show you the sex and read a
couple bits from a couple of them first
he argues intellectuals have greatly
underestimated the complexity of the
world
two
specialization has made people stupid
and that
maybe wouldn't have been the word i
would have chosen there but maybe it
would have been yeah and
certainly in some cases that's true and
here's one of the specific things that
he argues under that second of six
reasons
ways that he think we he thinks that we
have arrived at a dark age in modern
times
specialization fractures knowledge into
many different pieces and in our present
dark age almost nobody has tried to put
the pieces back together
contrary to popular opinion it does not
take specialized knowledge or training
to comment on the big picture or see
conceptual errors within a discipline
in fact a lack of training can be an
advantage for seeing things from a fresh
perspective the greatest blind spots of
specialists are caused by the uniformity
of their formal education
the balance between generalists and
specialists is mirrored by the balance
between experimenters and theorists the
20th century had an enormous lack of
competent theorists who are often
considered unnecessary or too
philosophical theorists like generalists
are able to synthesize knowledge into a
coherent picture and are absolutely
essential for putting fractured pieces
of knowledge back together
now this is completely simpatico with
many of the themes that we have you know
had in our lives been exploring since
you know since we were undergraduates
actually
um but
one of them in particular uh just to
just to bring the like okay but how does
that operationalize like how does that
work in real time
is that
that science relying
on funding from external agencies the
you know the three letter agencies like
nih and nsf and dod
means that
the
the scientists and therefore their
employers which is mostly the
universities that is you know higher ed
the institutions academia at large
prefer
more expensive science to less expensive
science and of course we we would all be
better in a system where the more
cheaply you can answer a question the
better off you are right um but that is
the opposite of the system we have now
we have a system where the incentives
weren't exactly the opposite of that
and um theorists
people who put fractured pieces back
together as is sort of what we do on
darkhorse but is very much what brett
does in in life and has done as as a
scientist both you know in your graduate
work and in ensuing work
in the you know in the in the many years
since then uh doesn't take very much
money to do
right it's it's about thinking it's
about accessing people's ideas and
people's brains and thinking about how
they go together it generally doesn't
take instrumentation and chemical
reagents in modern times you do need a
laptop
you need a laptop you need a laptop but
you know at some level so do we all
right
so
it is
in some ways and in often the cheapest
kind of science to do and this is also
true incidentally of much of field
science which also has ways into meaning
that
the reductionist world of lab science
doesn't and has also been
undervalued by the move towards science
being privileged based on how expensive
it is uh which again is backwards from
how it should be so the idea that
uh theorists are too philosophical i'm
remind
i'm reminded of lots of conversations
that we've had over the years with with
various people who were confused on this
front um but one of them is i once said
to a historian who was dismissive of the
ability or
value of scientists and science to have
anything useful to say about history and
this struck me is
absurd in part because evolution like
geology is explicitly in historical
science right and so i said well
actually let me know let's talk about
all of the ways in which trying to
reconstruct trying to understand what
happened in human history and trying to
reconstruct what happened in like parrot
history or rock history
actually uses many of the same tools
many of the same philosophical
underpinnings around for instance
history happened once you can't ever go
back and change that history but what we
understand about what is true may change
over time will change over time as we
hopefully get a better and better
understanding of of what actually
happened
our understanding comes closer and
closer
comes to be a closer and closer match
for actual reality as it happened uh but
will we ever get to 100 match with
reality
maybe not will we ever know if we've
gotten there how would we right like we
our tools are ways to get closer and
closer and some of the assessment tools
are ways to understand if we've gotten
there or not but um but it will never be
perfect
she thought this was hilarious honestly
this historian
and
when i pointed out that you know all of
us in the academy have doctors of
philosophy that's what a phd is a doctor
of philosophy
um
and that for me that points out that at
least at some point
in relatively recent history it has been
understood that what all of us are
supposed to be doing is thinking first
about the about the epistemology about
how it is that we're making claims
within our various fields of truth and
what those claims are based on and
whether or not they're justified
is that actually what most modern people
with phds are doing of course not but
that's that's that's the shame and the
degradation of modern science and
history and literature and all of the
other fields um that is not about the
fact that philosophy doesn't belong
there in the first place
so i want to introduce a concept that i
think is missing from this discussion
okay the problem is that by
dividing things uh between
empirical science
reductionism
and theory
the problem is that theory exists at
every level right
even in an experiment there is the sort
of the hypothesis that should be
motivating your experiment and then
there's the implication of what you find
for that hypothesis and then there's
what you do about it so they can exist
even at the finest scale
the missing term is synthesis
right so when we talk about putting
things back together we are talking
about and he does he uses the word yes
i missed it synthesize knowledge into
coherent picture
so
synthesis is basically
large-scale theory and very often the
experiment that reveals the result
the whole purpose of that exercise is
not the result the purpose of that
exercise is that it reflects back on a
hypothesis that you cannot know the
truth of
directly and so
you know if you take the example which
he alludes to here of the mouse telomere
issue
by predicting that wild mice would have
short telomeres the point was not that
wild mice have short telomeres the point
is if
the model that predicted that is true
then it also says
that uh senescence that is growing
feeble with age is likely an intractable
problem right the fact that mice have
short telomeres implies that the model
is correct and so knowing how to do that
job well is really important but the
most important thing about it
is that all almost all of the
experimental work that is done
is wasted if it was not embedded in a
rich synthetic
theoretical framework right because very
often and it's it's maddening as a
theorist sometimes to read the empirical
work that's been done because a lot of
it was like sometimes you say
you really needed an experiment to tell
you that
because the fact is everything we know
says that that's effectively certain and
yet you ran an expensive experiment
to uh
to discover here this is this this this
points to what we will talk about at the
end of the show i think um with regard
to the softest tree around we'll like
point to the scientific result that
shows that sex is binary right like
no one ever did that in empirical form
because it's unnecessary yes because we
can point to the 500 million to 2
billion depending on how you count years
of evolution of sexual reproduction of
binary sexual reproduction
and no no one has written the paper that
was peer-reviewed and this is you know
and and we'll get to this you know the
the things that people both inside but
increasingly especially outside
of
the academy of academic science
point to like the things that we now use
as ways to prove that we're actually
doing science and you know i used to say
in the classroom like okay well i didn't
show up in a lab coat with glassware
therefore i must not be doing science
right like what makes you a scientist
peer review is one of these things that
people trot out all the time well if
it's not peer-reviewed it must not be
science and we were talking about a
paper a couple weeks ago here in
darkhorse
and i don't i don't remember the
specifics but in which the author um
said of another paper
uh you know what they're gonna say this
isn't peer-reviewed yet but it has been
because i am the peer i have all of the
credentials and i have all of the work
that needs to have been done in order to
assess this paper and i am saying that
as have many of my colleagues that this
work is good so you know at some level
take your
institutionally sanctioned peer review
and shove it because that has now become
a tool of the orthodoxy and the
homogenization yeah it's a gatekeeping
tool so yeah peer review is not the same
thing as review by peers that's the
that's that and and he gets there he
does say almost exactly that um but
i don't know how to describe it but
in a world where science was really
science that is to say all of the people
involved in the endeavor
we're actually interested in the thing
that all of them believe they're
interested in and we
are told they are interested in which is
discovering as much truth as we can
because
it provides power for us to do more of
what we want to do on earth right in
that world it would be very upsetting to
empiricists that something had gone
wrong at the level of the theorists and
those involved in synthesis because
the idea that most of what we do
scientifically
the work that still goes on the
experiments that we run
is unnecessary also means that our
return on investment is ridiculously low
right it's like if you you know wanted
to find oil to fuel your civilization
and you sidelined the geologists who
could tell you where to look
like that would be dumb right you'd end
up drilling
most of your wells in places where oil
couldn't possibly be found and you could
have known that and you know so you
why would you do that and the point is
what we've got is a system where
science is functioning as a jobs program
what it is doing is it is employing
people to do science like things it is
not employing them to make maximal
progress towards some objective like
knowing how the universe works
and that's
truly alarming because we our tools are
getting more powerful not knowing how
the universe works is getting more
dangerous and so you know effectively if
you want a cheap elegant efficient
system you don't get to sideline half of
it in favor of the half that that needs
the grants right that would be a
self-destructive thing to do and that's
that's where we are that is where we are
um
under his third point
which is the one that i sort of i'm
going to spend the least time of he
talks about the lack of conceptual
clarity in mathematics and physics
uh he says patterson says in this essay
from 2021 more importantly within the
minds of intellectuals even if they
naively believe in the existence of a
measurement independent world
upon hearing the prestigious physicists
disagree
most people end up conforming to the
ideas of physicists who they believe are
more intelligent than themselves
and you know this is part of the trick
this is indeed part of the trick we all
if you've thought about it whether or
not you have a phd or you didn't
graduate from high school if you think
if if i say to you four
five disciplines that you could major in
in college and they are
history and literature and psychology
and
um
and physics you have a sense of which of
those people
are probably paid the most and which of
those people probably have the most
prestige
at the university that they're at and
the hard sciences and mathematics tend
tend to come with the most prestige and
you know there are a lot of people who
will say well that's because they're
based on you know they still have the
greatest relationship with with reality
uh and i you know that may be true it
should be true uh and there were those
who will say well it it actually does
provide the greatest return on
investment because there are practical
applications and because
physics may be the basic science but
from there you can get to engineering
and therefore you can you can end up
earning revenue
that's part of it too
uh but we we all know whether or not we
thought about it explicitly that there
is sort of a hierarchy of disciplines
that we have in our heads
and even people who view themselves as
the sense makers for everyone else the
would-be journalists in particular who
are very often uh not confident in their
ability to assess science or math
directly you know
which is to all of our detriment
are way too likely to defer
to the authority of someone with a
degree in science or math and basically
say uh when confronted with for instance
oh there's a whole bunch of people with
degrees in science who say x even if
there's now
dissidents for instance on the same
issue with the same kinds of degrees who
say yeah but here's where all the flaws
in that logic are
the smart people who don't do science or
math will say i'm just going to go with
the numbers i'm just going to treat this
like it's democracy and whoever got the
most votes must be the most true
and that's of course not how this not
how science works science is not
democratic and especially if a system
has been captured by a number of forces
if for instance we're living in a dark
age
then the fact that all of the people
inside of the system are saying the same
thing doesn't actually tell you anything
because there's a very high likelihood
that those voices are not independent
that you've actually got one giant data
point that says ah we believe x and
there's a whole bunch of independent
data points over here going actually we
don't think you're right and we'd like
to see your data that you keep claiming
you have and the fact that those voices
keep getting shut down
is
further potential evidence that maybe
there's something to be listened to
there
which actually goes to
um this problem of philosophy having no
place right it is a remnant that as you
point out resides in all of our degrees
right but it resides there as what most
people in you know most people who have
a phd probably don't spend a minute in
their entire career thinking about the
fact you know that it's a doctor of
philosophy but
this this raises a
a point right so we have talked here it
is in our book
about the idea of metaphorical truth
right metaphorical truth
are things that aren't literally true
metaphorical truths are not literally
true but they are useful they are
adaptive you are
at advantage if you behave as if they're
true because something similar to them
is true or analogous to them is true but
you can't spell it out yet so you need
them
but you don't want to mistake them for
the actual
uh article now this we apply this to
religion
for example but the problem is that
scientists don't get where it fits in
their day job
right
so scientists will frequently tell you
that they have no faith right that they
are faithless that that's what they are
they are objective and the point is no
that's what we do here yeah you couldn't
possibly be without faith because it is
actually
100 required in order for you to walk
into the lab and look into a microscope
and report on what you've seen the idea
that you
there are a lot of assumptions built
into the fact that you think you looked
into a microscope you think it exists
you think the stuff on the slide is real
and that
your report of it is something other
than random right it's not
likely to be wrong but it is a an
article of faith required but
in any case you if we go back to what we
were talking about 20 minutes ago
there are certain kinds of ideas that
you have to hold in order to do your
work
but the question is can you manage to
hold them with a degree of agnosticism
about how true they are right so that
you can go back and not be totally
crushed if they turn out not to be right
and
we could see this in for example the you
know the many worlds interpretation of
the universe right they're an infinite
number of trajectories there's a version
of you um
that is the same in every way except you
know it scratched its nose uh a minute
ago and you didn't right there are an
infinite number of these things well it
may be that you can make great progress
in physics by saying well let's treat
the universe as if they're an infinite
number of versions of it right which
doesn't make it right it may be that
there's some other way of explaining how
the universe works that way but if you
do mistake it is writing you say if we
if we behave this way it results in us
doing productive work therefore it must
be true then you've lost the game right
so it's really a question of
um
if the game is let's figure out what's
true as opposed to let's keep ourselves
employed
right exactly well in the let's keep
ourselves employed in fact it's
perversely useful to believe crazy
things right because people love hearing
about the infinite number of universes
right and they don't love hearing we
don't really know what the truth is that
this works instead of but let's tell you
the you know the the spackle we use to
cover the hole in our knowledge here
really unglamorous yeah it's really it's
really un un uh un glamorous
um and you know that's the game you know
if the game was really how you know
let's take whatever contributions you're
going to make and see how long they last
and those who win the game are the ones
who contribute something that lasts the
longest that is useful farthest into the
future well then the incentives aligned
correctly if it's you know let's see how
many people you can razzle dazzle at the
moment well okay you can razzle dazzle
people with magic which doesn't make it
true indeed
patterson's fourth point uh with regard
to how it is that we got here uh which
he's positing is a you know hundred-ish
year-old
uh
period in in the dark in a dark age at
the moment
four the methods of scientific inquiry
have been conflated with the processes
of academia so we've already said this
but his section here is quite good what
is science he asks in our current
paradigm science is what scientists do
science is what trained people in lab
coats
science is what trained people in lab
coats do at universities according to
established practices science is what's
published in scientific journals after
going through the formal peer-review
process good science is what wins awards
that science gives out in other words
science is now equivalent to the rituals
of academia
real empirical inquiry has been replaced
by conformity to bureaucratic procedures
if a scientific paper is checked off all
the boxes of academic formalism it is
considered true science regardless of
the intellectual quality of the paper
real peer review has been replaced by
formal peer review religious ritual that
is supposed to improve the quality of
academic literature despite all evidence
the contrary the academic publishing
system has obviously become dominated by
petty and capricious gatekeepers with
the invention of the internet it's
probably unnecessary altogether
well so asterisk here i would say what
makes what what keeps it useful even to
those who don't think they're benefiting
from it but who are working still within
academic science is it allows them to
decide oh actually i only read pieces in
these two journals and therefore if it's
in one of those journals i'll read it
and if it's not i don't have to pay
attention uh which is not a scientific
approach but it does help widow well
wait wait so you're dividing two things
one is the question of whether this is a
quality improver and the other is
curatorial right right exactly yes
following standard scientific procedure
sounds great unless it's revealed the
procedures are mistaken peer review
sounds great unless your peers are
incompetent upon careful review of many
different disciplines the scientific
record demonstrates that standard
practice is indeed insufficient to yield
reliable knowledge and chances are your
scientific peers are actually
incompetent
i'm reminded of another story in which i
was talking with a colleague
a scientist about another colleague
who had a phd such that she was
supposedly a scientist
uh and he said well so and so says x
therefore
uh and and she was in a slightly
different sub discipline from either of
us
so and so you know dr so-and-so says x
therefore um we can build that into our
model and i said she doesn't do science
what i said she's not a scientist what
are you talking about she has this
degree i mean i've actually literally
had this conversation with a colleague
10 years ago maybe at evergreen
and he said on what basis i said now i'm
going to turn that around on you
where have you ever seen her think or
think in any way that is scientific
it i'm not saying she's a bad person and
i'm not saying the stories she tells
aren't interesting and many of them may
be true but that doesn't make them
science
and uh this was
completely shocking to the the guy i was
talking with
who i who i do
uh regard as a scientist who i have seen
think scientifically and do scientific
things
but it seemed to him like the ultimate
sign of disrespect
that her having been stamped on the
forehead with a phd in a science from an
institution that is allowed to do such
things
that i having been stamped on the
forehead with a phd in a science by a
different institution
having actually done science and having
actually been engaged in teaching
undergraduates how to do science
should say about another such person
i've seen no evidence there's any
science there
and being willing to do that is part of
what is absolutely necessary if we are
you know if we are in fact in a dark age
in order to pull ourselves out of that
tailspin
everyone who can still think and he was
able to look around and go okay where's
the truth has got to be able to say that
thing over there not science nope
so
we are
stuck in a
puzzle
in which the labels on the boxes are
almost
devoid of information about the contents
of the boxes and so this works in both
directions right because the way
the
uh scientific endeavor the social
scientific academic endeavor unfolds
involves the need to do certain kinds of
work right you wouldn't want to report
an experiment that you didn't run so
there must be an experiment which
requires you know certain people to you
know take a pipette from here and i put
it into there right so
to work to make that cheap
universities
primary investigators effectively hire
people
to do the work
that work gets paid for in the form of a
degree which does not say that you ever
demonstrated the ability to test a
hypothesis or even a deep understanding
of what a hypothesis is right where they
come from and how you would test one
right there's no there's no guarantee
that somebody with a degree that says
they should know that knows that at all
and so lots of people with these degrees
simply as you point out they don't
behave in a scientific way they don't
think in a scientific way and if asked
to do so they couldn't because they just
haven't practiced right they haven't
learned the counterintuitive part of it
the thing i used to say is that some
people wouldn't know a hypothesis if it
hit them in the head yeah wouldn't
recognize it as such like what what is
that thing that just came at me well
people for example do not notice
that paper after paper in journals
called things like science
don't have a hypothesis in them right
right that should alarm you because it
is an essential piece piece of the
puzzle as we have said every paper ought
to either lead to a hypothesis it's
perfectly valid to make a scientific
observation that then suggests a
hypothesis in need of testing or it
ought to report a test of a hypothesis
but to have no hypothesis anywhere in
evidence in a paper auto alarm everybody
who knows how science works and it
doesn't back when i was being asked to
do peer review because that is one of
the pieces of free work that
working professors are asked to do
my primary feedback on almost every
paper that i saw was what's the
hypothesis i can like i i actually stop
there like
what is the reason to assess any of the
rest of this
if this doesn't appear to have been
hypothesis driven in which case again if
there's no hypothesis like maybe cool
story maybe interesting observations
then conform the basis for hypothesis
and if you frame it that way and don't
claim that this is a complete piece of
science okay
but they're always you know in these
journals as if like oh and here's the
science we did like but you didn't
because you didn't have the hypothesis
going into it
yeah absolutely and i mean
we sometimes talk about the fact that um
there's no good way to teach somebody
how you come up with a hypothesis right
it's really a matter of a lot of
thinking about you know if this thing
that i suspect is true
is true then these other things that i
can measure will turn out to be this
surprising thing right that's not a you
know it's a how do you think a thought
kind of a thing you have to discover it
on your own
um so it's no surprise that people's
educations in science almost all hiccup
at that level and so what they end up is
so specialized that there's only two
hypotheses in an entire field and the
whole you know your whole career is
involved in studying and around those
things but you've never generated one
but anyway i wanted to point out the
other thing lots of people who have the
degree
don't know how to do science because it
didn't come up in their training right
but lots of people
who do science didn't end up with a
degree because for one thing
they probably got driven out in the
process of being trained you know in
this bogus art and so they ended up in
other things they ended up in
engineering they ended up starting a
business something like this um and you
know we know a number of these people so
were you to try to or driven out of the
mainstream economy entirely and there
are a number of people who are
extraordinary at scientific thinking um
who you know you are have would have a
hard time finding uh
with any economic mark on the world
yeah that's true there are a lot of
people who are unfortunately sidelined
entirely and then a bunch of people
who've repurposed for
something economic or design oriented
but
if you were to try to bootstrap
a
new you know we have the argument in
this uh
paper here that maybe we're headed out
of this dark age well presumably that
would be the result of people's
scientific work again becoming visible
as a result of the fact that the academy
has failed but the thing is i guarantee
you a lot of those people are not going
to be degreed in fact it might even be
an obstacle if you were trained in the
nonsense version of science you might be
less good at doing the good version
that's right
so his fifth line of evidence for uh
we've been in a dark age is five
academia has been corrupted by
government and corporate funding now
we've said a lot about this already of
course
so i'm not going to spend more time
there right now but number six human
biology psychology and social dynamics
make critical thinking difficult
he says
therefore the real causes for error are
often socio-psychological not
intellectual an absence of reasoning
rather than a mistake of reasoning this
feels very very important to me
rather than grapple with difficult
concepts nearly every modern
intellectual is trying to avoid
embarrassment for themselves and for
their social class they are trying to
maintain their relative position in a
social hierarchy that is constructed
around orthodoxies they adhere to these
orthodoxies not because they thought the
idea is through but because they cannot
bear the social cost of disagreement so
there's at least two distinct things
there
both of which we've already talked about
today but
it is
it is the key problem with many of the
supposedly heterodox communities that
emerge now
and you know or or were emerging for
instance
before two years ago and then kamcovid
could not see their way
to disagreeing with any of the orthodoxy
over in covet space
and this is you know this is this is
part of why
uh it is not sufficient if higher ed
were to be fixed if the academy were to
be fixed it is not sufficient to scrape
the sort of rancid frosting off the top
that might be considered to be woke
ideology or um movements to
to shame everyone with a different
demographic than yourself which is you
know the actually you know racist and
sexist and all of this stuff that is
flying under the banner of diversity
equity and inclusion it's not sufficient
to just scrape that frosting off the top
because what you're left with is an
equally rancid cupcake underneath and i
don't i don't want that cupcake anymore
that i want the frosting right we need
an actually new thing built with
built with
a combination of enlightenment ideals
and and values and the the thinking
around how to stay
how to keep
both things in your head at the same
time this is what we think is true
this is what i now think might be true
instead
uh the probability is maybe i don't need
you know depending on what the work is
maybe i do or don't need to keep precise
probabilities alive around how
how what i think the likelihood is of
the orthodoxy versus my new idea but as
i explore ideas further on remember
always that i'm sitting on some
foundation that is probabilistic and
that if that fails what happens to the
rest of my argument that that little
thing right there which we talked about
at the beginning of this hour
seems to be something that almost no one
is prepared to do and yet i think from
our experience teaching undergraduates
um almost everyone can do
well
first of all in passing i love the idea
of scraping the rants and frosting off
the rotten cupcake i think i think you
hit the nail on the head with respect to
academia right there but um
the
the problem
is that
only a tiny number of people a have the
instinct to notice that they are engaged
in a
gigantic emergent
fraud right and that even if you begin
to get that sense
you very quickly get the message that
you're going to be
injured
in a most profound way if you continue
to investigate what
is down that road and so you know if you
think last week we talked about
um
why ryan cole seems to be one of
the only pathologists calling attention
to new patterns that they're seeing in
medical samples
in the last year
well
what could possibly explain the absence
of other pathologists we did hear from
we did hear evidence of some other
pathologists who are doing this work
okay um but so he's not no doubt no
doubt he's not perfectly singular but
nonetheless if this is happening
generally then the point is why aren't
all the pathologists uh
pointing this out and the answer is what
happens if you discover
that um
in my job
if i do my job i will lose my job right
what do most people do when they
discover that doing the thing you've
been hired to do is going to cause you
no longer to be hired to do anything and
the answer is most people don't have a
backup plan they don't have a mental
architecture for
thinking what that implies
if i stand up alone i'll get shot i need
a critical mass to stand up with me
everyone knows that they can't be first
and so how do you even how even if you
knew that there was 20 of your field who
was willing to stand up that you'll
actually all stand up
right at the same time as opposed to
kind of wait until you're maybe second
right and you know things that would
have seemed impossible in advance and
this is not about um academics but
things like
the vaccine mandates kicking nurses
out of work when what we need what we
are told is that we need nurses more
than ever and i believe that we need
nurses more than ever and yet at exactly
the moment when we actively and 100 need
skilled professionals
those skilled professionals are not
being allowed to work because they stand
up because they are standing up to what
they view as unconscionable mandates um
both for themselves and frankly for for
others as well and so if
if the system such as it is is willing
to do that to nurses of course it'll do
it'll do it to anyone it'll do it to
anyone and it can do it at a level that
is almost impossible to believe right
what are the chances that the covid
dissidents would include
the guy who invented the underlying
technology behind the vaccines right
that's a stunning piece of information
but the point is he is dismissed as um
he's dismissed in every way right he's
everything they can possibly say that
he's making it up it doesn't matter that
he's got the receipts that he's got the
patents and all of this so the point is
there's no it's not even like well i
don't want to stand up alone you know it
doesn't matter how large the number of
people are or how credible they are or
most importantly how predictive they
have been
right when the people who have correctly
predicted the you know the pattern that
would emerge in the pandemic are
dismissed as charlatans and the people
who got everything wrong are the ones
doing the dismissing it should be
obvious that if you're going along with
the people who haven't gotten anything
right yet you're on the wrong team but
nope that's not how it works the fact is
the real message isn't
those people are charlatans and they're
wrong the answer is if you stand with
those people you're going to get hurt
yeah
you don't want to get hurt do you
one last uh short excerpt from this
remarkable essay
individuals who individuals who consider
themselves part of the smart person club
that is those that self-describe as
intellectuals and are often part of the
academy have a difficult time admitting
errors in their own ideology
but they have an exceptionally difficult
time opening errors by great minds of
the past due to group dynamics
it's one thing to admit that you don't
understand quantum mechanics it's an
entirely different thing to claim neil's
board to not understand quantum
mechanics the former admission can
actually gain you prestige within the
physics club the latter will get you
ostracized
all fields of thought are under constant
threat of being captured by superficial
consensus by those who are seeking to be
part of an authoritative group
these people tend to have superior
social and manipulative skills are
better at communicating with the general
public and are willing to attack any
critics as if their lives depended on it
for understandable reasons since the
benefits of social prestige are indeed
on the line when sacred assumptions are
being challenged
so that actually just perfectly wraps up
what we were just just
discussing um
maybe
it's it's already
an hour into our conversation maybe it's
time to segue with all of this in mind
to one of the couple other topics that
you wanted to talk about today
sure um yeah there were a couple that
were on on my mind um
yeah one of them has to do with
an indication in the way
people
are and are not speaking up that
something isn't quite right in the style
of thinking right so what i what i
wanted to point to was
as i mentioned last week there is
something
galling about the gaslighting of the
vaccine injured right it's just simply
it is galling at a human level that we
would fail to take care of people who
just simply did what they were asked and
it came up badly but here's here's the
extension to that thought
it ought to be galvanizing it doesn't
matter
which camp you were in you might have
been in the camp that said look covet is
in a terrifically dangerous disease
we have this tool that is going to limit
its spread which ultimately it did not
but at the time people thought that it
would and it works if people get it in
large numbers it will fail if people
don't get it right so if you were in
that camp
right and the point is look let's be
adults about this
medical technologies
have unpredictable effects they may be
overwhelmingly useful but it doesn't
mean nobody gets hurt
right so people who advocated hey just
get the damn vaccine ought to be united
with those of us who were like hey wait
a minute there's an awful lot of
uncertainty around these new
technologies there's more novelty to
these technologies less testing and
you're proposing a mass vaccination
program so if these things turn out to
be really terrible you will have done a
tremendous amount of harm
shouldn't matter which of those two
camps you were in or if you were in some
third camp
anybody
ought to be able to see that
whether
the harms were very rare
or very common it is
incumbent on us morally and in terms of
the system functioning to figure out how
many people were hurt and to treat them
very very well to study the conditions
that they have to figure out what what
it is that alleviates these conditions
and make sure those people are taken
care of and the reasons for this are
many right one we can learn from our
errors in thinking
two we encourage people in the future to
follow
good advice
with respect to you know we have reason
to believe this is safe and we want you
to take it because that will increase
the effectiveness of our campaign to
control this pathogen right if you
really believe that if you think that
that's what was being said
then it is also something that you
should be interested in that we find out
just how rare these
you know these adverse events were and
that we treat those people very well so
that the message next time isn't you're
going to be left you know to your own
devices if our new medical technology
injures you no matter how good a
treatment no matter how good a piece of
medical technology there will be some
adverse events this just this this is
just a truth of the universe right you
know you
there you know sometimes broccoli harms
people right sometimes aspirin harms
people sometimes some particular novel
treatments harm people and
pretending that this isn't happening
is uh it raises the question of who
would actually be interested in treating
the people who did what we were all
being told was the right thing to do and
they went and they got the treatment
uh who benefits from gaslighting and
actually making it hard gaslighting
those people are making it harder for
them to move forward with their lives in
a way that uh is is the maximally
effective and healthy given that they
actually were injured right and so this
is actually
this is the the conclusion of this line
of thought is
the absence of the people who were so
enthusiastic and so aggressive
about the vaccine campaign the absence
of those people from the
chorus who wants the vaccine injured to
be taken seriously by the medical
establishment is conspicuous the only
people who should have an interest in
not seeking out the vaccine injured and
treating them are people who wish to
obscure how many of them there are and
so can't afford to have them counted and
that shouldn't include any of the decent
people right if you got it wrong and
let's just say maybe we don't know which
side had it wrong but everybody who's
interested in finding out ought to be
united and seeing those people treated
well
right so the absence of of some of these
folks from uh
from
that chorus is conspicuous and it raises
questions about what is really occurring
so i i hope that people who hear that
and were on the
um the
aggressively pro-vaccine
side
in this argument think about it and
realize yes oh of course i want those
people treated it's in our interest it's
in our interest now it is the morally
right thing and it is certainly in our
interest the next time there's some
vaccine and a question about whether or
not it's safe to take we need to know
how how safe these were for us to be
able to do that next time absolutely
absolutely
so uh finally you wanted
to revisit
the epidemic of sophistry and i believe
that's actually the title that we gave
to an episode where you talked about
sophistry a fair bit
yeah um yeah i wanted to talk about the
epidemic of sophistry because um we've
had this uh film emerge this week which
you and i have not seen it's paywalled
but we've certainly seen clips of it
what is a woman a matt walsh
piece
and
it has sparked a number of you know
investigations of that question
and
it it alerted me to one thing that i
thought needed exploring
there is a trick
that is played it's a legalistic trick
and the trick is oh you will you say you
know women's sports uh should only
include people who
you know born females
you know
well
you know are you able to define those
terms right
and the implication is that a failure to
be able to define a term indicates that
you're a poser for using that term
certainly you shouldn't be using terms
you can't define
in fact that's not the case in fact we
do this all the time and in fact you
would be utterly hobbled in
communicating almost anything if you
only were allowed to use words that you
could define with a reasonable degree of
precision yeah and so actually zach
would you put up my uh
elephant tweet
and put it where we can read it if you
would
it's a lot of dead air yeah it is a lot
of dead air okay so uh
[Music]
i put up the following thought
experiment i said consider this if we
choose a thousand adults at random and
ask them to define elephant it is
unlikely that any of them could do it
but if we showed each of them a thousand
animals only one of which was an
elephant they would all identify it
correctly okay now what do i mean by
this lots of people came back and they
said well i think lots of people could
do a decent job defining an elephant no
i promise you you can't because the
definition of an elephant is inherently
phylogenetic the definition is an
elephant is the descendant of the most
recent common ancestor of all elephants
um
people are gonna hate that they're gonna
hate it but
that's circular using elephants to find
elephants
it's just true though it's just simply
true and anything else you try to do
runs a foul of all kinds of uh
ambiguities right if you try to define
it based on the large ears the large
stature the trunk whatever it is the
point is you're giving characteristics
that will help you recognize one and
indeed they are characteristics that
will help you recognize one but they
don't define elephant and so the point
is for a thousand people chosen at
random to be able to identify an
elephant from a thousand animals chosen
at random
that says that there is something
unambiguous about elephantness right it
does not the ability to recognize that
thing does not depend on your ability to
spell out what the synchron of
elephantness is
right and so
my basic point is
we all know what a woman is right in
fact in this case the definition is
pretty simple and we've gotten shy about
it because we're afraid of all of the
questions about ambiguities at the edge
that we can't answer even though there
is no fundamental ambiguity zack
you can put up my screen now
so this is this is not your point right
but but
one of the points here is actually
every
human being past a certain age should be
able to easily define what a woman is
just as they can define what a man is
and
i did so
in the end of march on my sub stack in a
piece i called i am a woman and a
biologist and no you shouldn't need to
be a biologist to be able to do this
a woman of course is an adult human
female and i then define adult
human and female female being the point
on which people seem very interested in
being sophists
females i posit are individuals who do
or did or will or would but for
developmental or genetic anomalies
produce eggs
eggs are large sessile gametes gametes
are sex cells in plants and animals and
most other sexually reproducing
organisms there are two sexes female and
male
like adult the term female applies
across many species female is used to
distinguish such people from males who
produce
do or did or will or would but for
development or genetic anomalies produce
small mobile gametes that is to say
sperm or in the case of plants pollen
so in this case
there is a simple definition and
everyone actually
should be able to have that right at the
tip of their fingertips but
you know the elephant question
not not now not here it'd be interesting
to get into you know what you know how
does
an elephant how does
asking people to define elephant differ
from asking people to define
woman
yeah and um
part of part of the issue although they
are both biological at that one level
is that elephant
is a
lineage yep and female is not woman is
not a lineage and this is part of why
actually sex
is completely different from for
instance race and so we lump things like
sex and race together and we talk about
privilege and discrimination and all of
this but sex and race are completely
different kinds of concepts
and
whereas elephant is a solid lineage
concept within evolution of biology race
not so much but at least it alludes to
the idea of lineages and sex doesn't at
all because we all come from an equal
number of male and female ancestors so
let's take
that
well unless sorry unless you go back far
enough to the asexual stuff at which
point we all come from 100 female
ancestors right so let's take those
three
cases right elephant race and sex
elephant race and sex because what this
really says and in fact if you would put
up that other tweet uh a a twitter
mutual a friend of mine uh amazon eve
who
uh i believe is a trans person
challenged what i had said
on twitter
and asked me well if you're going to do
this with sex
effectively
why not race
and the answer is
you don't get to have it both ways right
i don't actually i don't want to have it
both ways but what i want to do is apply
the exactly right tool kit and get
exactly the amount of biological
information in each of these categories
and here's what you've got
elephant when heather says elephant is a
lineage
it's a clade right there is zero
ambiguity about what is and isn't an
elephant because there was a most recent
common ancestor of all of
the elephants
and there is the set of all of its
descendants you are either descended
from that animal or you are not if you
are not you are not an elephant if you
are you are inherently an elephant no
matter what you look like so not to say
that we will ever have that degree of
precision right so you said there's zero
ambiguity but you know hearkening back
to what we're talking about early on in
this episode the fact that science
is a toolkit designed to align what we
understand to be true as closely as
possible with what is actually true that
doesn't mean that we will a ever 100 get
there nor that we will know that we are
there when we do get there well no this
is a matter of logical necessity in
other words if i meet a person let's say
that a purse i meet a person who
was dropped on the doorstep of an
orphanage
right as an infant
has no memory of what took place before
the event only develops the ability to
have memory after they've already become
a member of the orphanage right i can
say
that this person had two grandmothers i
can't say who they were
right but i can say that this person had
two grandmothers and two grandfathers
right and they had one mother and one
father right
that's just a matter of logical
necessities yeah i'm just talking about
the boundaries of of elephantness
it doesn't matter the point is i don't
even you know the term elephant and it
occurred to me as we
launched into this that we could be
saying pro-basidian right we could take
the larger plate of elephant-like things
or we could take elephant as you know
one of two species right
extant species it doesn't matter the
point is you tell me which thing you
want to define and i'll tell you that
the definition is the same it's any
descendant of the most recent common
ancestor of that group
so operational not so much but that's
not what we're trying to do here we're
trying to define it
what it is that all of those people who
identified the one in a thousand
creatures as an elephant have identified
is that they've identified the
descendant of that most recent common
ancestor and their failure to come up
with the scientific definition says
nothing about their ability to actually
recognize an elephant uh from an array
from a lineup right which we know
because they'll all agree on which the
elephant is exactly right so we know
it's real
we just can't specify exactly how they
got there but it's really unambiguous
now the thing is
as you point out woman is not a lineage
right because woman is like you take a
lineage the human lineage and then you
turn off half of it by virtue of a
developmental switch that went one way
or the other in each person right now in
some places it may have been ambiguous
but your point has been from the
beginning that there is a thing which as
far as we know is never ambiguous which
type of gametes do you make or would you
make if
you had been intact and so the point is
is it the same as lineage no is it
biologically ambiguous no
um
so the point is you you can do the thing
there so what about amazon use point
about race well you can do this there
too
the fact is race isn't the same kind of
thing as woman and it isn't the same
kind of thing as elephant right because
let's say that you had two people who
were as embedded in a given race as
anybody ever is right you take somebody
who is as close to
i don't know
how about maasai
or um
chinese okay han chinese and maasai
right
they fall in love
they have an offspring what race is it
well uh razor's edge between those two i
don't know right
does that mean that masai doesn't exist
no it certainly doesn't does it mean han
chinese doesn't take this no it doesn't
what it means is that we know the edges
of this concept whatever its biological
nature is are imprecise right does that
invalidate it no you know when does a
pond become a lake right are there lakes
are there ponds can we talk about the
different kinds of creatures that tend
to inhabit them we can is there a you
know an exact you know
cubic centimeter of water that causes
something to jump from one category to
the next no is that a crippling fact no
so
so i mean we we often talk about the
fuzzy borders in biology not
um demonstrating anything about the lack
of reality of the categories so you know
as you as you descend a mountain into a
valley the
our inability to say exactly what point
the mountain becomes the valley doesn't
render either the concept of mountain or
valley unreal
and in fact you know that because the
river will be in the valley
that is one way that you know that i
would say um same thing with a pond at a
lake the distinction between them
um seems even more fuzzy
but it is that is a little tricky
it's a little it's a little tricky to
invoke precisely here because
in fact what renders
lineage uh
fuzzy is because of sexual reproduction
right and in fact in fact actually the
um
the clip from our private q a that was
actually released today i think is us
talking a bit about lineage selection
and showing um a visual that my graduate
advisor arnold kluge
used to show with you know individuals
making choices about reproduction and
you know make and you know making babies
and them going on to make babies with
other individuals and you know you scale
out and out and out in time
in time not in space and you end up with
these neatly bifurcating trees that say
you know and then the species became two
species became four species etc
and that allied's a whole bunch of the
actual stuff that happens at the closer
in level temporally where you know you
and i
have created a lineage with our two
children but we do not come from the
same lineage and so you could you there
is a fractal nature of lineage but also
a reticulating nature of lineage uh that
makes it very different and you know it
explains like you know you can't you can
pick two very distinct and relatively
homogeneous populations on the earth
like han and maasai and say they are
unlikely to have very many
recent ancestors in common say within
the last
i don't even know at least within the
last thousand years okay
um but do they actually share an
ancestor of course yeah we all do we all
100 percent do right so it depends on
how far back you're going and so this
it's it's it's scales and it's fractal
and uh lineage is both real and also
reticulating and it depends on you have
to specify what what you're talking
about and so with regard to elephant
it sounds like a circular definition but
it's actually not you know an elephant
you know is
all of the members all of the
descendants of the most recent common
ancestor of elephants
we can't do that with and you could do
that with human you know with homo
sapiens without ever you know being able
to or being forced to define who that
first homo sapiens was
we can't do that with race because race
doesn't work that way right because we
are too reticulated because we are too
intermixed and we always have been and
we always will be
so i want to point out the the bad
mental habit that this reveals yeah
the reason that we get into trouble
about this right the reason that people
say well if you're going to do that with
sex then you know you're going to be
forced to do it about race it's like
well do what
do science sure
less yeah um
but
but the point is there is a sense that
look
you're telling us what team you're on at
the point that you start saying look the
thing that defines what sex you are is
what gametes you are built to produce
right well then you're going to get
stuck with that when it comes to race or
something like this
and the point is look
if we take you to a forest right and we
say look i want to show you something
about this forest come with us right and
we'll lead you into the forest and then
we have promised to bring it back yeah
and then okay check this out we've got
an electron microscope in the forest in
the forest with a long extension yeah
it's going to melt but um but anyway now
the fungus is going to eat it
yeah it's going to disintegrate into the
forest at some point but but my point is
look is the truth of the things that you
need an electron microscope to see in
the forest somehow
not the forest no of course it is right
we can look at the you know the
structures inside the cells of the
creatures of the forest we can zoom out
and we can see entire organisms in the
forest we can
look at how the forest changes over time
the ebb and flow of the different
species all of these things are elements
of the forest and the point is our job
as biologists
is to apply exactly the right biology at
exactly the in exactly the right way so
that the conclusions that are built out
of it are actually robust right is it
possible to do it perfectly no but the
point is yeah let's do as well as we can
just as you know is it possible to play
a perfect game of tennis i doubt it
right but you play as well as you can so
the point is look yeah
is biology relevant to race of course it
is is biology relevant to sex of course
it is right is it relevant to does it
apply the same way to both of course it
does not right there are pieces that do
there are pieces that don't and so look
that's all we're saying is you know
you've got this toolkit it's full of the
most amazing stuff and it applies to all
the questions you care about
can we figure out how to apply it so
that it is revealing to everybody right
it doesn't you know it's not it doesn't
hand a win to some team right you get a
complex interesting result that you'll
then have to grapple with the
implications of but why wouldn't you do
it why would you relegate yourself to a
universe
of teams right the team thing
it's a loser it's not you know and in
fact it goes exactly to the conclusion
of
that
patterson that patterson essay the fact
is this is not a productive mechanism
for figuring out what's right right the
team thing is a loser and
we are losing the advantage that comes
from not dealing with things that way
for the the lack of the appropriate
toolkit indeed
oh well
are we there i think we might be there
all right
this has been fun
yeah i hope you guys found it so as well
we will be taking a short break then and
coming back to you with a q a you can uh
get
ask you can get you can get questions
you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
now and into the q a we will be back in
15 minutes or so with that
we encourage you again to
join either or both of our patrons where
you get not only access to for instance
that monthly private q a
or a higher tier level
one of brett's conversations that he has
with people you have another one
tomorrow morning that's right
but also there is a a lively and
wonderful community a dark horse
community that you could access to
through both of our patreons on discord
and we finally uh e-met some of the some
of the people who are helping to run
that community yesterday i guess it was
and i was just i was i was so thrilled
to see
to see everything about it actually um
i'm i'm really excited by what is going
on the discord community and if you are
interested in
in in coming to know people who are also
curious about what is going on in the
world and not being scolded when they uh
they run a foul of current dogma then
consider consider joining the discord
community at either of our patreons
so until we see you next
be good to the ones you love eat good
food
and get outside be well think
scientifically
[Music]
you